[Music]
as millions recover from kogit 19
economies around the world are still
exhibiting signs of ill health
global trade remains disrupted prices
are rising and for many goods and
services demand is far outstripping
supply
so what should governments do to help
aid economic recovery
and after covert 19 how can economic
reform help to change the world for the
better
our experts answer your questions
after all the stimulus provided by
governments will we see hyperinflation
or a period of depression
so i i would say that neither of those
are very likely possibilities or
certainly hyperinflation is extremely
unlikely that would require the sort of
collapse of
of government and there's no reason to
think that the stimulus we've had during
the pandemic is going to lead to that
sort of
failed state situation which is
necessary to bring about hyperinflation
what's more possible is
a period of high inflation we're already
seeing that with inflation over central
bank's targets especially in the us
increasingly in the uk and a little bit
in the eurozone there are economic
theorists out there who say that you
need a little bit of inflation after a
sort of one-time
burst of stimulus like we've had and
that may yet prove to be correct it's
one of the most important questions for
the world economy whether the inflation
we're seeing is likely to be persistent
i don't think we're going to see a
period of depression unless the virus
takes a real turn for the worse
in a way that requires no
many more restrictions or consumers to
stay at home again perhaps the highest
risk of a prolonged slowdown
could be in china
it may not be as serious as a depression
but there are various shocks hitting the
economy at the same time right now
the delta variant
means that parts of the country have had
to go into lockdown
you've seen power cuts in part of the
country because of high prices of coal
and provinces rushing to meet strict
national carbon emissions targets
and then the government itself is is
trying to curb
huge amounts of debt in um the property
sector we're starting to see the housing
market slow and you can imagine all of
that creating a bit of a perfect storm
and
growth in china coming off quite
significantly from the high rates of the
past
why is there a shortage of workers and
what can be done
i think that
in 2022 we're really going to find out
uh what is going on in the labor market
people have talked about uh workers need
to stay home to look after their kids
people have talked about uh unemployment
benefits keeping workers out of the
labour market
people talked about people being
worried to go back and work in proximity
to the public during a pandemic or even
in you know packed warehouses and the
like
gradually all these factors should start
to recede the really interesting
question is has there been a
uh shock to how people look at life and
look at their priorities and look at the
world of work
as a result of the pandemic clearly
working from home has changed uh a lot
for people in their and their day-to-day
lives but i don't think we should rule
out the potential that uh uh workers are
just looking at uh at their things like
their work-life balance very differently
and and think about the necessity of
work uh differently and if there's been
a sort of change in people's preferences
during the pandemic then that could also
uh create shortages in the in in the
labor market
too once we know what's causing those
labour shortages once we have a better
idea of what's causing those labour
shortages we might have a better idea of
how to go about resolving them or
governments might have a better idea of
how to go about resolving them
to some extent
wages should start to rise and your
people back into the labour market or
into the industries where demand is
growing really quickly the governments
might need to start thinking about
retraining or linking benefit payments
to returning to work
how are disrupted supply chains
affecting the global economy and what
can governments do
what's happened is there's been this big
surge in demand for goods uh caused by
stimulus and caused by people not going
out as much as they were
and so good's expenditure is much higher
globally than it is normally especially
coming out of america and that has
caused supply chains to run up against
what look like quite hard limits that
aren't going to be able to unwind
themselves at quite the pace that they
did uh in 2020 when you were looking at
reorganizing supply chains to get a
produce ppe and that and that sort of
thing what you have is the world economy
saying we can't quite cope with the
level of goods demand and what needs to
happen is the world economy needs to
shift a bit back more towards spending
on services to get economic growth from
the service sector
rather than pushing more and more
stimulus and more and more spending into
goods where supply chains really need
a bit of time for the investment
in things like shipping and microchips
and so on to enable the greater
production that would satisfy
that demand for goods
what economic policies could governments
introduce to help tackle climate change
the european union is planning to spend
about 750 billion euros
on something called the common recovery
fund which will include plenty of
spending on green infrastructure and
green projects
um
president joe biden in america has also
got got plans would like to pass
um a bill involving spending on um retro
everything from retrofitting homes to
green infrastructure
what you really want though and
something that this
that we've argued for at the economist
is to price carbon
why has economic recovery from the
pandemic been so uneven around the world
there are probably three reasons why
the recovery from the pandemic has been
so uneven
one is that the virus hit various
countries at different times
so the delta variant of the corona virus
for example started out in india made
its way to britain and europe and
america and is now working its way
through southeast asia so those
countries went into lockdown and imposed
various restrictions on activity at
different points of time
we've also seen different rates of
vaccination and um
richer countries have tended to have
higher rates of vaccination and that
that's enabled them to stay open much
longer
and the final reason why recovery from
the pandemic has has been uneven
is because of the extent of stimulus
that we've seen
enacted in a lot of these places so in
america for example we saw huge amounts
of stimulus being unleashed quite early
on and that meant that people have means
to carry on spending even when they were
stuck at home
how was vaccine rollout around the world
impacting the economy
so the level of vaccination determines
the extent to which economy is exposed
to the virus vaccinations have been way
higher in the rich world um overall and
so that's enabled the rich world to uh
uh uh break that link between the spread
of the virus and hospitalizations
whereas um the emerging world isn't in
the position to do that
that said
people
were very worried about the spread of
the delta variant in emerging markets
and the ability of it to disrupt
production but what we've seen
more recently is the delta wave in
emerging markets start to come off a bit
despite the overall lack of vaccination
the other thing i'd say is that even
within rich countries
you have that division
a lot of the american public are still
not vaccinated and that's clearly
interfering with
america's economy in that the spread of
delta has reduced or seems to have
reduced consumer confidence somewhat
is the gap between rich and poor
becoming wider and how should this be
addressed
we've written about how at a global
level what we saw from
1990 to 2010 was two periods of catch-up
where the poor world uh grew uh faster
than the rich world and uh
incomes began to converge we had this
big fall in global inequality as a
result of globalization and
people getting richer especially in
china as a result of their integration
into the global economy
in the 2010s that stalled a little bit
ketchup became slower and then obviously
the pandemic has uh created this divide
between rich and poor because of the
distribution of vaccines and the ability
to offer stimulus to the economy so
there is a sense in which at a global
level progress seems to have slowed
somewhat it's
very important if we want to continue to
reap the gains that we've seen uh since
uh the 1980s and 1990s in terms of
global inequality uh coming down as
people are integrated into the global
labor force that governments resist the
urge to
put up barriers to trade to put up
barriers to immigration to stop the
global economy integrating because that
has been a tremendous force for good in
the lives of billions of people
thank you for watching you can read more
about the world economies recovery from
the pandemic by clicking the link below
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
you